my name is amber Amoz I'm the chef and
owner of Mossad our bakery here in the
West Village of New York City and today
I get to try everybody else's chocolate
chip cookies
[Music]
there is a nice number of chocolate
chips which I really like doesn't really
smell like anything though which is kind
of strange she didn't have to
unless stick my face into it smell it mm
Oh 20 sweet really sweet something that
I always look for in cookies that isn't
just kind of like monochromatic it
shouldn't just be crunchy it shouldn't
just be dry I shouldn't just be sweet I
like about this is you have a little bit
of the crunchy and the chewy and you can
see that even in the difference in color
it got a little caramelized you can see
that it's soft because you can't hear it
but then when I bite into it you can see
that it's crunchy so I do like that it's
got different texture it's not my
favorite but I'm going to turn it away
[Music]
this is a much more sizable cookie that
looks really big and delicious
I think there's nuts in it not that easy
to break open it looks good it's just a
kind of cookie that would be really good
warm something that I would want to have
right out of the oven you can't be mad
at a warm chocolate chip cookie even a
mediocre chocolate chip cookie worm like
you want to propose to it the less air
you haven't something the less it's
gonna dry out and you look at a cookie
you look at something you see a lot of
little air pockets everywhere so it had
a lot of opportunity to be a little bit
on the drier side it looks like it has a
lot of nuts and here the thing about
nuts is they suck moisture
I think the nuts kind of fought with the
cookie and they might have one this
would actually be a really good cookie
to put with ice cream because it'll hold
up against the ice cream I would love to
try this cookie again but I think it's
time war
first glance I like the size and it
looks like it's nicely baked too because
it looks nice and golden it's smells
good it actually smells like brown sugar
which I love more of a carmelization and
more of a caramel taste you face a
little bit more homemade there's good I
feel like this is a cookie that could
kind of do the trick I also would
imagine they're sold in packs of more
than one that's also kind of a cookie
that you're gonna want to eat more than
one of the chocolate tastes a little bit
waxy but I'm not really mad about it my
mom looks so much better
Oh what just happened I like subway
cookies
[Music]
this is a big cookie sometimes size
doesn't always make it better it's
really heavy when you see this happening
on the outside looks like it's almost
kind of like blood a little bit on the
outside that's actually excess butter
that means it wasn't mixed all the way
if you take this little outside piece
this is probably gonna taste almost
exclusively like butter and the other
parts may be a little bit drier you look
on the back you can see that they use
really big chocolate chunks which is
kind of nice so I break it open it's
really almost kinky inside but it still
looks really nice and moist inside and
it definitely looks like we used a lot
of brown sugars you're getting a little
bit more common well taste hmm it's a
little bit too dry for me or somebody
like Starbucks having a cookie like this
is probably a great idea if you're
having a cappuccino you can dip it and
it's not going to disintegrate
[Music]
it's kind of a nice size actually it's a
little bit like the Goldilocks of
cookies it feels like a sizable weight
breaking it open is nice Wow that is
more chocolate than I have seen in any
other cookie it's which not what I
remember it tastes a little bit more
homemade this feels like somebody might
have made this for me i think
everybody's mall how to mrs. feel a lot
of what i'm tasting is probably my
memory more than the cookie itself these
are a little bit blonde for me
Rhonda's not bad but in your cookies you
want them to have a little bit of color
one of the things that we really like to
do with cookies have them be baked
enough and have to have enough sort of
golden color which this doesn't have but
it has a lot of nostalgia
so definitely gets points for that so I
had a lot of chocolate chip cookies
today if you're gonna make them at home
I would recommend two things you always
want to think about the balance of sweet
and salty before you bake them you
sprink a tiny little bit of Maldon salt
the other totally great tip age your
dough so you're gonna get better color
and you're also gonna get sort of a
better flavor at the end of the day no
matter where your chocolate chip cookie
comes from how much chocolate it has or
how long it's been aged it's gonna be
amazing because it's a chocolate chip
cookie
[Music]